one of my favorite things about this
film was the opening credits and how he
induces all of these young names that
we've never seen before on the big
screen and so what was it like working
with all these kids who were in their
first movie ever yeah I mean it was such
a joy I was very nervous about playing a
mother not being one myself and you know
living for myself you know being on your
own you're very selfish and then you
have to somehow care about these this
huge family but they were so absorbent
so curious so excited and there's
something immediate and raw about
working with a child because they don't
know how to lie they don't know and so
you have to keep them engaged and they
they work from an instinct that is so
inspiring and one that you then end up
trying to channel at all times you know
Robert gives Fiona so much great advice
throughout the film that gives her hope
helps her believe in herself and i'm
curious whether or not he gave you
advice that may be changed your
perception of the film or maybe change
your life as the father to a door to
myself i know for a fact that this
experience of doing this film has
impacted just how much i want to impact
how life in terms of you know everything
she can go on to do and my son's as well
i have three sons but also beyond that
you know I've really seen the power of
mentorship and advocacy through through
being around him so I have to ask the
question what it's like watching other
people play you I imagine that's got to
be a surreal experience when I wish to
move it was kind of emotion like it just
draws me back like I felt like just made
of your life every time I had to first
cry was over time yeah how was appealed
I I know there are many movies made
about people but it is common that those
people have to first to die so well as
for you two to be alive and you see
yourself being portrayed I think it is a
such a wonderful thing it's a big enough
room do you feel like it's getting
easier to make these kinds of movies as
a champion of female driven movies I
have always made my movies you know and
it's always a struggle
it's never easy but it is about time and
pretty good to see that finally people
have woken up to the fact that women are
you know infinitely as good or sometimes
even more commercial than men can have
proven it's not it's nothing to do with
a gender situation but I must say to
make a movie is to make a movie and it's
a struggle you know whether you're a man
or a woman what matters is when you
reset the pieces she's witty she's
opening play again strongly I got thick
skin
you